-Yesterday, PETA,
the People for the
Ethical Treatment of Animals,
tweeted that they think
it's time to get rid of
common phrases that
mention cruelty to animals,
like "kill two birds with one
stone" and "beat a dead horse."
And they went on to say that
using these phrases
is the same as using
racist or homophobic language.
Here to talk about that
are two of our writers,
Jenny Hagel and Amber Ruffin,
in a segment called
"Don't Drag Us Into This."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Hey, PETA.
-PETA, What's up?
-You compared
anti-animal language to racism.
-And homophobia.
And as a lesbian...
-And a black lady...
-...we just want to say...
-Don't drag us into this.
-Look, you do good work.
-Great work.
-I'd say great work.
-Fantastic work.
-But I think people
can see what you're saying
without you comparing
the suffering of animals
to the suffering of
minority groups.
-It's like comparing
apples to oranges
-Or hamburgers
to voter suppression.
-To understand
that something is bad,
you don't have to compare it
to another bad thing.
Things can be bad all on
their own, like Spanx.
I can tell you how bad they are
without comparing them
to World War II.
-I can tell you
why I hate deviled eggs
without talking about polio.
-Oh, I love deviled eggs.
-You're gross.
-As gross as slavery.
-See? That's what
we don't want you to do.
-Now, Jenny's suffering
isn't the same as my suffering.
-And Amber's suffering
And a duck suffering
sure as [bleep]
isn't the same
as either of them.
-Also, let me get this straight.
Are you saying
when we use an expression
that mentions animals,
you think it hurts
the animal's feelings?
A bull doesn't know you said,
"Grab the bull by the horns."
Bulls don't even speak English.
-They speak Spanish.
And to any bulls watching,
I just want to say...
[ Speaks Spanish ]
-And I can see the things
that Jenny goes through
as a gay American,
and they can be valid.
And they can be real without
being tied to my experience.
-Same.
-Yeah.
-Amber getting stopped
by security every time
she goes to JCPenney
isn't the same --
[ Laughter ]
You laugh. It happens to her.
-Big-time.
-That's not the same as JCPenney
being able to fire me
in 30 states for being gay.
-The Supreme Court
not passing marriage equality
until three years ago
isn't the same
as some white lady
not wanting me to marry her son.
P.S., I did, and he loves it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know you want
animals to be safe.
We all want that.
-I'd take a bullet
for this puppy.
-I cannot say
the same thing about cats.
They are terrible.
As terrible as
gay conversion therapy.
-That's what we
don't want you to do.
-Look, my point is --
if you think it's a good idea
to compare minority groups to
animals in any way,
you have had a bad idea.
I am not a cow.
I'm a fox.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I am not a bunny.
I'm a whale.
Wait. I'm not good at this part.
-I love you,
but that was not good.
-Okay.
-Look, we're glad that
you're fighting
for the ethical treatment
of animals.
-Fight the good fight.
-Just don't drag us into this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪